Airport system. We will now transition to
Houston Health and Director
Williams director
Stephen Williams and Darren Asher and council
member, pilot, vice chair. Would you step in the seat, council Member Jackson,
1 minute.
At this time, I want to welcome director Stephen Williams and Darren
Asher to provide the Houston Health Department budget. The floor is yours.
Good afternoon. As you said, I'm Stephen
Williams, director of the Houston Health Department. I'm here to
present our General Fund and Special Fund budget for
the fiscal year 2023. I want to start by introducing
my staff there behind me, so I don't know where they are.
I have with me Judy Harris, who's Chief of Staff and
deputy director. Also Darren
Asher, who's our chief financial officer and administration.
Also is Amber Hague, who's behind me, also who does
one part of our administration.
Stepping in for our communications officer is Dr. Faith Foreman,
who's administratively over that unit right now.
But you should be familiar with portfolio Villarrell,
who is our Pio and Councilor Liaison.
Also with me is my assistant, Randy Presley assistant
Director, Patrick Key, over Environmental Naomi Macys,
assistant Director for Clinical and Multi Service Center
Operations, Dr. Shannon Bivens, the Deputy Director for Public Health,
Evelyn Schaefer, deputy Director of Human Services and
Financial Division Manager, Shamika Marshall
I want to express publicly my gratitude for the
staff, especially during the last two and a half years. Although for
you all, things might seem relatively calm in the community.
With rates of COVID slowly rising, we're still providing
testing and vaccination services to the community.
At the same time, we're resetting these services that we
have within the Houston Health Department and transitioning
to what we would call possibly a new normal. But I don't
know that any of us really knows what that is. Now go
to the next slide, please, with vision, mission and goals.
Our mission is to work in partnership with the community to promote and protect the
health and social well being of Houstonians and the environment in which they live.
It's not practical to try to do public health alone. Community involvement
is key to our success. Our partnerships were certainly instrumental in our
ongoing COVID response, certainly related to testing and
vaccinations and the critical for effective
interventions within the community. We don't think that we
can do it all. We exist in public health to improve
access to care, to prevent spread of infectious disease
to promote opportunities for healthy living and reduce burden
of chronic disease which most people die from protect the
community from environmental hazards to improve health and well
being through human services improve health of mothers,
infants and children and prepare to respond to disasters
and emergencies. And certainly we try to do that in a culture
of excellence. Next slide, please.
This is our functional organizational chart. In our General Fund,
it supports 374 positions. Within our
Special Funds, it supports 285 positions
which totals about 660 FPS between
those two funds. Our administration, I'll tell you, is just 9.9%
of the General Fund, especially funds.
But I have to add in our grant funds. Our grant funds
support 675 positions and this
is not including COVID sources.
Those funds are approximately $63 million.
That will be a total for normal operations of about 1336
FTEs for Florida department administration is 7.6%
of that. Well, we have COVID with the $91 million
that we have annually for COVID. You need to add another 485
positions to that, bringing our total positions within the health department
now to 1821 for the entire department.
Administration of all of that is still reduced to
6.3% of our budget. And I say that because
without administration we can't really get the job done.
I'm extremely proud of the scope of the programs and services
that we provide. Although in some of our programs
I do not believe that the scale in programs like our Don,
our Reentry program, see to Succeed, our scale should
certainly be much broader to match the scale of the problem
of the condition that exists here in the city of
Houston. The next slide is a summary
of our major services. Did something different this year?
I wanted to give you an idea of how much the General Fund
supports public health within this community.
If you look at the services that are highlighted in green,
you will see that our General Fund primarily supports environmental
health, which has food safety, special waste and pools.
Our clinical services out of four health centers,
eleven multi service centers, and hopefully in
the 2023 budget year we'll add on a
leaf and with a new Sunnyside facility, thank God,
and a regional lab. But if you look at those programs
that are in red, there's limited or no General Fund support for those
programs. TB, Immunizations, Maternal and Child
Health C to Succeed, which provides free vision exams and
glasses to children. My brother's keeper reentry.
Certainly WIC is a grant funded program. All of our COVID
operations and testing and vaccine is supported by grants. The programs
that I did mention are primarily supported through grants and special revenue
funds. Next slide, please.
This slide lists state and local codes and ordinance that mandates
some of the public health services that we provide, such as Disease Prevention
and Control, environmental Regulatory service and vital statistics.
Chapter One and 121. The Public Health Reorganization Act
authorizes municipalities to enforce laws to protect public health,
receive grants, appoint a local health authority. And that would be Dr.
David Purse. Our local ordinances, chapter 21 and
22 establishes the local health department.
Subsequent ordinances establish certain programs such as air pollution
and vital statistics. Next slide,
please. The medical nature of
our operations requires specialized licenses and certification.
This has a major impact on recruitment intention given our proximity to
the medical center. As I mentioned in the past, our department
was the first health department in Texas to become accredited.
We was the second major city in the country to become Fab
accredited during the Pandemic. We became reaccredited,
and we are accredited for the next five years to 2026.
With the accreditation, hopefully we can demonstrate increased accountability
and credibility to the public, to the funders, certainly to you and
partner organizations which we work with.
Next slide, please.
Licenses and certification that are required. Our business requires certain
licenses and certification, as you can see the
requirements for a laboratory and pharmacy. I want to highlight
that our lab does not only support our clinics, but it's a specialty lab supporting
17 surrounding counties. Our stat lab provides onsite lab
testing and our specific multi service clinics.
The Bureau of Laboratory Services provide a variety of clinical and
environmental testing and support of various health department
programs, including our lead TB, Epidemiology,
Environmental Services, Hi V. STD.
Our wastewater surveillance. And I want to really highlight wastewater
surveillance because it has really gotten
national attention. It's a partnership with Rice thanks
to Carol Hednock and Public Works and her folks are very cooperative
during the Pandemic having their staff actually collecting those samples.
We have actually been a source of support for other jurisdictions
within the country that are wanting to get into wastewater
testing because they see ours as a model,
given that the Public Works wastewater
system as it exists within the
city. Of course, with wastewater surveillance,
we're able to predict COVID-19 trends from one to two weeks
before other surveillance metrics like testing.
And of course, we use that information to guide our
strategies related to COVID. I have to tell you
that even though the numbers are low now,
we're still concerned with several geographical areas within
the city where there are low vaccination rates coupled with
other social economic challenges.
Hopefully you will be seeing a number of
contracts where we're trying to partner with more community
based organizations to have further reach into those specific
communities. The next slide, please. I have been doing
this presentation for about 18 years, and I have to always do
this slide just to highlight the
level of investment, the general fund investment,
and the health department. Overall. This slide
illustrates the city's net fund general fund investment in public
health. It's only for $40 million.
The Health Department's 23 target is $65
million. 2 million of that is to cover environmental health
special revenue funds. But please understand that
we generate $25.6 million in
revenue. That's where we get that number from.
But it's also to note that out of $40 million
investment,
19 million is in restricted funds, which means that
I only have control of $20 million in general fund
to really do public health programming and
that's of a budget of $165,000,000
totally if you include our grants and
other special funds. The next slide,
please. Our revenues by Fund Fund
100 represents an increase of $3 million in
revenue, and it's related to multiple grants in support of COVID-19
that are generating additional indirect cost recovery.
When we bring in grants, we hire people, we actually increase
the bottom line of the General Fund because of indirect cost.
This revenue is driven directly by our
ability to hire grant staff, which means the more grant staff
we hire, the more indirect dollars we can actually draw down
from the grants. In Fund 22,
an increase of approximately $2 million reflects a one
time transfer from the General Fund to cover our environmental
health experience expenses.
This program staff activity actually generate enough
revenue to cover the program expenses.
Fund 2010 represents a reduction of approximately
$3.1 million in revenue due to the 1115
waiver actually coming to an end, we are slated to get
our last payment in July of this year.
Overall, in our budget you will see an increase in revenue of
$2.2 billion.
The next slide actually is a highlight of the
summary of revenue by Fund. I'm not going to go over that because if you
go to the next slide, I can actually talk more specifically about those
funds and Fund 100,
the expenditure breakdown. Of course, 60% of the General
Fund supports personnel for administrative services,
environmental health, oral health and clinical staff, and the health Clinics
laboratory Morality Service Centers. It's really a repeat of what I said before.
40% of the General Fund supports non personnel items.
Of that, I'd just like to note that only 18% of the non personnel funds
support departmental operations. We primarily rely on
grant and special revenue funds to make ends meet
when it comes to buying equipment,
supplies and services.
The next slide, please. Expenditures by Funds
this slide is a summary, so I'm going to go to the next page,
which breaks it down by detail. All funds
highlight expenditure highlights. In Fund 1000,
expenditures increased by $5.5 million
due to $1.2 million in hope and
pension increases. $1.6 million for
new a leaf facility, which only represents
the third time in 18 years that I've actually gotten General
Fund money for programs in public health. The only
other two times was when we
needed more overtime in jail health, which was
a mandated services, and we got a cut in
federal dollars for our TB services and we needed to backfill some of
those dollars. So I'm grateful. Even though it's the third time in
18 years. Fund 2002
increases include additional funds for expansion of our AAA
Veterans Affairs program. Of course, that's grant funded funds in 2008
2009 there were no significant changes, and funds in 2010
no significant changes. But as I said, we're getting that
last payment for that in July of this year.
Fund 2023 Special Waste Fund reflects
the transfer eleven FTEs to the Health Special Revenue Fund
from 2002 as part of the department's
attempt to reduce expenditures.
Really, this is really charging a portion of consumer health
staff to this Fund. The next slide,
please.
Personnel versus non personnel in Fund 22.
This is a catch. All fund used to manage revenue that is generated for
a variety of programs. This includes Environmental
Consumer Health RFID program, which is
really the RFIDs that you have on the
food trucks. Our Veterans Affairs that I
mentioned earlier, medicaid Administrative Claiming,
which is really based on a cost report that we are due
for providing services related to Medicaid
clients and also vital records and parking garage fees.
54% of all funds support personnel.
This is related to the issuance of ambulance permitting support
the Veterans Administration program by assisting veterans with
services staffing to support parking garage at our
stadium facility and staff to support nondirect
services paid for with Medicaid dollars such as
billing. 46% of those
are of those funds are
non personnel items. 3% is in restricted accounts.
The 72% is for non subrecipient contracts
and basically that's used in environmental health to replace obsolete
equipment in our RFID program and to
operate our Digital Health Online food Managers class.
Next slide, please. In laboratory services. This is pretty straightforward.
The revenue from this Fund supports our lab operations
and provides funding for laboratory equipment and laboratory
and and laboratory services.
A lot of our grants I'd like to mention actually support some of our laboratory
services too, but this is the General Fund
supportive Personnel and non personnel on swimming pools.
69% of the Fund supports personnel.
31% supports supplies and services,
including mandatory education and training and testing supplies.
The Fund 2010 Essential Public Health
Services want to take a little bit more time to highlight
what this Fund had actually done over the last few years? This 1115
waiver supports both waiver programs
and essential public health core services.
In the past years, we have used these funds to support general operations,
general Fund operations such as laboratory services, TB control,
maintenance contracts and clinic supplies. This Fund
has been a lifesaver for the Department operation and allowed
us to be responsive in the emergencies. Over the last ten years,
we have minimized the negative impact of General Fund reductions
over the last few years by using these funds.
We have an average of about 200 FTEs supported
through this Fund. Over the past five years,
we have funded programs, as I said earlier, like C to Succeed.
Projecting savior smiles, my brother's keeper reentry
supported lab services, our Don program,
chronic disease, as well as our administrative services
division. These funds are limited.
So in the next year, what you will see is a restructuring plan to reduce
both FTEs and operational support.
Next slide please. Fund 24
23 special waste our fog program.
Basically, this Fund supports our fat, soil and grease
inspections. It includes support for 48.3
FTEs. The Fund is 84% personnel and
supports those activities. 16% of the
Fund support operations,
36% is allocated to restricted accounts and
64% is allocated to supply services and equipment.
Next slide, please. 2023 budget
Expenditure net Changes okay,
of course, the first section covers the $61.1
million, which is our current FY 21 22
budget. Excuse me. Section two covers
the operational operating budget adjustments.
You see in that adjustments for our
1115 waiver, our intergovernmental transfer
funds, and also where we had received some council
funds. The third section contractual
mandated adjustments related to benefits, restricted accounts
and our new a leaf facility. As I mentioned earlier.
The fourth section is the proposed budget includes $2.2
million transfer to the Special Health Revenue Fund for community health
and environmental consumer health. Those are to fund those to
transfer those eleven positions to that cost center.
The current budget minus operating adjustments, plus mandated adjustments equal
to a budget of $65.6 million,
which is a 7.4% increase in our General Fund
budget. The next slide gives our budget
history. Probably need to explain it to you a little bit,
because if you note in FY 19,
the adopted budget does what didn't include jail health.
But remember, we had to operate jail health for an additional year
because the Joint Processing Center didn't open
for another year. In FY 22, the estimate
includes a 1.2 restricted account adjustment for the $750,000
hope adjustments in FY 21.
Just so that you will understand what we
did there in that fiscal year, we redeployed General
Fund staff to work COVID and so we built those expenses
to those COVID grants which resulted in
a reduced expenditures to the General Fund.
And in FY 22 you will also see
that resulted in the restricted accounts increase,
which basically it is going to charge us more than what we have
budgeted because we brought on more people and more computers.
That pretty much explains that.
That's the end of my financial budget presentation
for FY 23. Thank you
Director, for your presentation. A couple of questions. What are
the areas of our city that have the low vaccination rates?
I'm not going to guess. Why don't I send you the map that we have?
During the height of COVID we actually did a weekly
report showing areas that
were concerned, there were target areas,
just what we characterized as high COVID vulnerability
areas based on an index that was produced by developed
by CDC. Yeah, if you could send that to all of our offices, that would
be great. We have some areas,
I'm sure. Let's go to
slide eight, please.
So to get clarification on this slide again,
with 40 million, you all are able to generate revenues of 25
million.
Yes. So if we were to allocate more dollars to
you from the General Fund, would you be able to also generate more revenue?
Probably not, because the areas that generate the revenue
are primarily in our environmental health area where we're collecting fees
for permits. If I had more General
Fund dollars, of course I would spend them in programmatic areas.
I think we need to focus more on chronic disease. I think
we need to focus more on balance,
youth balance. And I think that we need to
also focus more on maternal child health issues.
So comparison for the general fund dollars that we allocate
estimated, how many dollars will you get in grants?
I can tell you what we know that we're going to get. We're going to
get about $65 million in the coming year
in grants, and that's all over the map.
We will have probably about $91 million in
COVID dollars, but those dollars are going to end in about a year.
So the $65 million you'll get in grants,
is that including the COVID dollars or no? No.
So outside of the COVID dollars, you're still going to get around estimated $65
million in grants? Yes. And that's about
what we usually get. Our budget for the last couple of years have been running
about, what, $160,000,000,000 within that
range for everything special funds, general funds,
and grants. You want to use your microphone, Mr. Ashley, for everything,
special funds, general funds, and grants by 165.
Thank you. Next, we have questions by Council member
Amy Peck. Thank you, Vice Chair. And thank you,
Director, for the presentation. When you were talking about the 1115
waiver restructuring and adjusting and moving personnel
from that fund, can you just talk about that a little bit more for clarity?
So you're moving personnel from the 1115 waiver that we were using to
pay for their salaries to where's that money
coming from now? Well,
and I'm sure you've heard this from other department directors,
but the general fund doesn't support some
of the essential programs that I think our department should be
running back. Starting in, I think,
2011, 2012, we were able to access
1115 Waiver funds. With those funds, we were
able to bring on programs that I thought
we needed to be running within the Health Department.
For example, see, to succeed my
Brother's Keeper program, our reentry program
is funded by 1115 Waiver.
So when those the 200 positions I mentioned,
I can't just put them on the general fund. The general fund can't absorb
them. So I will have to find other resources
if we want to keep those services. If I'm not able to recoup
enough revenue, we will have to actually reduce those
services. Okay, so at this point, you're just looking for grants
and other ways to pay for them. You're not moving anybody to the
general fund that was on the 1115 waiver?
My boss wouldn't let me do that. Okay.
And then my last question is about environmental health.
Something I've talked to Public Works about when it comes to inspections
is working with other departments so that we're looking at if it's an apartment
complex or a house that needs certain inspections, that we're working
together and not working separately. So can you
just talk a little bit about how well that has been from
your perspective, working with Public Works to make sure that everything is being inspected
kind of all at once? I think we have a very good working relationship
with Public works, especially as it relates to the apartment complex,
because sometimes a complaint will come into one department
or the other. And our staff has been around long enough
that they know what's our scope of responsibility and
know to bring those other departments in. I think that
the Waste Water Surveillance Initiative is a good example of
how Public Works and our department are working well together.
One thing that it's in the works. I haven't
really told staff about this, but they'll know now. Council Member Kayman is
carol and I were out at an event related to lead
and we thought that we could actually broaden those activities because
of just the age of the houses. And in the last week or
so, we're passing emails back and forth talking about how we
were going to approach this.
Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Vice Chair. And thank you, Director, for all the great work you've done
during COVID on slide four. Thank you for that. The red and green
one. You were talking about administrative funds,
and I wanted to be clear.
Those grant funds do come with administrative funds built in.
You're not supporting all of those with general fund admin?
No. Yeah, we couldn't support and they have varying
percentages, I'm sure, of administrative funds associated with those.
They do. Okay, great. Houston permitting
and I rarely get any complaints about the Health Department.
Houston part of Houston Permitting. How many employees
do you I mean, I know swimming pool safety and then what else do you
do? Like at HPC? Do you know how many FTEs are over there
in the permitting system from hell? No, I don't. But Patrick,
four total. Okay. And on
temporary employees, you mentioned that as we are seeing decreases in
COVID and the grants funding, I mean, do you anticipate
that some of the temporary employees or some of the people we've taken on will
not no longer be I mean, how long do you anticipate
most of the COVID related temporary employees?
Well, an interesting thing has happened during COVID especially during this
point in our other programs,
whether they're grant funded in some general fund positions. We have a lot of vacancies
on that side. So those individuals that have been working no good.
Yeah. We are looking to figure out
whether or not there is a fit. We don't want
to run the risk of letting everybody go and then we go
into another surgeon. So we're engaging in some cross training.
Sure. Okay. And finally, I was going to ask the
kinder and Hobby School study that talked about a tale of
two departments that came out in December. Did recommend some areas
where we could possibly do an MoU with the county. Not talking about
merging departments or anything. Don't beat
me up between us.
Okay. But if you could opine a bit.
They list several areas of overlap and disease control and
prevention, dental services, environmental, public health, women and Children's
health, Nutrition and Chronic Disease Program, public Health Awareness
Policy and Planning and Finance Administration. I mean,
could we start small with some MoUs? And you've done a good job, like with
air quality monitoring and stuff like that with the county, but where could we do
an additional MoU to possibly gain Efficiencies one
day? Okay, I'm going to make a general comment because they made
a comment publicly that somebody told me about. I wasn't
very pleased with the report because I do not think that they accurately
represented the differences between the department.
I will give you an example. When they looked at our immunization
program, they compared our putting shots in
arms and the county's putting shots in arm. That is a
minor part of our immunization program.
We have relationships with all of the providers within
Houston and Harris County. We're a state contractor that
have to monitor our Vaccines for Children program and
all of that. None of that stuff was included, and so I think they fell
short of that. But to the core of your question, there are
a lot of things that we are doing with the county. We mentioned our
One Safe, Houston. The credible messenger stuff.
We have been working with them. There are some things that we already
have in place that they just missed.
We were in the middle of COVID My staff did send me
responses, but they weren't that complimentary, so I didn't send them.
But we are in the process of working with the county, and what
we're going to do is come up with an MoU that really
will formalize the relationships that we have.
What I'm looking at is actually modeling it after an
interlocal agreement that I'm familiar with between the
City of Austin and Travis County. And I lived
that life for years, and so I know how
that can be modeled. Thank you. I'd appreciate just being kept in the loop on
that. I'll do it. Thank you. Council member Abby
Cayman. Hi, Director. Hi.
First off, I really want to recognize the department under
your leadership for everything during COVID
We quickly talk about COVID and talk about shots and arms,
but the extent to which you and
the entire department have had to deal with not
only an unprecedented global pandemic, but the primary
purpose, you all were at the tip of the spear in terms
of the response to that. So thank you to everyone
for everything that you did and continue to do because
it's still ongoing. But on top of all of that, all the programs you
continue to run. Working with my office on the lead survey that
we did in Friedman's town, even just
on the phone right now trying to work through some of the formula shortage issues.
You all continue to be that
first line of response and caring for Houstonians every single day
to that point. I don't know if you mentioned it.
How many Houstonians does the health department serve?
Well, there are different answers to that
question because it depends on the program.
For the most part, our department covers all of Houston,
so the total population of Houston. But for certain
programs, we cover all of Harris County. The Immunization
program that I mentioned earlier, one would think that our
responsibility is only the city of Houston, but it's not.
It's all of Harris County. We are
the state's point for Immunizations within all of Harris
County for our laboratory services. And I mentioned this.
We actually have a 17 county catchment area.
So it really depends on the program.
But our core is Houston, our Seed to succeed program, because we partially
fund it through grants. We service all of the school districts
within the region, not just HISD.
I appreciate that answer in the context I'm going to switch
gears really quickly. I'm going to ask an unpleasant question.
Looking at page nine. The Swimming Pool
Safety Fund.
I'm not as familiar with that program. And given
the fact that I don't want to be asking this question, I don't want us
to be in the position where we aren't going to have pools open this
summer. What we've heard from the Parks Department is because we don't have enough
lifeguards, we're going to have to reduce the number of pools open. Does that impact
the Pool Safety Fund in terms of operation or what's needed
there? We will.
Patrick Key is our assistant director, and shortly after he
came in, naomi Macias, who is newly
appointed assistant Director, was actually over consumer
in that. But several years ago, we developed
a strategy where we cross train people to make sure that
when swimming pool season arrived,
we were able to redeploy staff to actually ensure
that pools were inspected. It's one of the programs where I
get calls from my neighbor if my community pool is
not open or there's a problem with it. So it's like that. So the resources
that are allocated here are still being utilized even though the public
pools may be limited. In operations,
we inspect parks pools. Actually, that was one of the first things
I did when I came here. Joe and his folks were inspecting
their own pools, and we had an agreement that
it would probably be best if the Health Department, which inspected
all other public pools, inspected parks pools.
Also. I'll follow up on
the question. I know my time is I'll put you back in the car.
Thank you, council Member Jackson. Thank you.
And thank you, Director Williams, for just all your work and
just the partnership. I know my office worked closely with you. We were able to
get in the incredible messenger program rolled out and other initiatives. So just
thank you and your staff for just your commitment. As I'm looking at
the major services and I see all the services
that your major services under Human Services,
the highlighted ones, is just disturbing to see that. There's no
dollars allocated for General fund dollars allocated
for these services, like Aging and Disabilities and Reentry
program. This is Human Services. And so my
question to you is, how many grant writers do you have? Because it seemed like
you're spending all your time writing grants to serve the people.
Usually in health departments, the folks that direct
the programs write the grants. We don't have special grant writers,
except sometimes our planners or
analysts will write grants. But you will find people all
over our department writing grants.
Okay. I know recently with the One
Safe Houston, there was anywhere from
I know there was a lot of money from the ARPA dollars.
So does the budget include those dollars, or is
it we did not include opera dollars.
We did not include the opera dollars in this report because
we were still going through the process. Okay, all right.
It would only add $2 million to the budget.
Okay, well, we need those. I'm talking about from my department. Oh,
really? Yes. I know how to know that. Maybe three,
but I'm at you only 1 million for reentry,
and then I think a half million for Credible
Messenger, and then maybe another million for
street interventions.
Okay, thank you, sir. All right, Council Member
Cayman,
I'll submit a question to you all related to the pool fund,
so I can understand a little bit more. But lastly,
Director, you've already flagged some of the needs.
And what I'm asking every department is, as we look ahead, we have the financial
constraints imposed by the city based on revenue caps and other things.
But looking ahead, what do we need to be aware of on the horizon
for the needs of the Health Department? I think
I mentioned the areas that I think need most support.
Chronic disease is something that I think we need a further investment in
maternal and child health issues and certainly youth
balance issues. But the
thing that also that we
need to look at are some of those wraparound services that
we need to provide to clients in order to be successful regardless of
the core program that they're accessing. For example,
for years, even in our program as Chorus
TV, our staff had to
find sources for food, sometimes housing,
to ensure that the clients were readily accessible so
that they could take their TV medicine. And that's for the overall
protection of the community.
I don't want to just say, yes, we need more General Fund
money, and leave you with the impression that we're not
aggressively looking for
increased revenue. We've been very active statewide
looking at the transition from the 1115 waiver.
There is uncompensated care fund.
We're trying to maximize our ability to draw down funds
on, and of course,
we continue to seek grants.
Director, I want to thank you again for your presentation. To you and your entire
team, we thank you all for all that you do. We have immense
appreciation for the work that continues, especially during the
pandemic. That was a time of real
uncertainty, in a time that we were continuously moving,
continuously trying to react, and from setting up
the testing sites to setting up the
vaccine sites, all the logistics that went on with that
through your leadership and your entire staff and team, we want to say thank
you for all that you do. Thank you. And you were dismissed.
We have four virtual speakers
and two in person speakers. We will start with the virtual
speakers. The first is melissa Martinez,
please press star six.
Melissa Martinez, please press star six.
Geo Grocer, please press star six to unmute.
Geogroph star
six to unmute.
Jason Oliver hello,
and thank you for the health presentation.
It's really concerning to kind of hear health come back year
after year, saying that they really could do
quite a bit in terms of, say, chronic disease, youth violence,
and maternal and child health with more general
fund dollars. I'm interested because you talked about that's, what you would prioritize
in terms of programming. Have you priced out any programs for
these areas that could be implemented during fiscal year 2023?
And then second,
because youth violence, of course, seems like an issue that we should really care about
right now. Second, behavioral health interventions announced and
approved during last year's budget don't appear to have been implemented yet,
and it sounds like those aren't housed there. But are those initiatives
housed within the Health Department? And then why is implementation seemingly
delayed? I'm going to start
with your first question. Many times the priorities of
the department is going to be led by the director of that department. So they
are the ones to identify certain programs
that they believe are beneficial, and they will put those in as
line items for us to consider and put forth.
Of course, there can always be additional programs and additional dollars that
would be needed for advancing those programs,
but that discretion remains with the director.
And your second question was my
second question was about the behavioral health interventions that were
announced last year, right. All of the MCOT teams that
were especially important as alternative responders are
those housed within the Health Department. And then what's
going on with the delay in implementation? Why is implementation taking
a while? We're going
to have to get back to you on that particular question to make sure that
we give you the specifics. So if you want to please send
us that question via email to District E at houst
gov. We'll get back to you shortly.
Okay, thank you. You're welcome.
Amanda Psy.
Hi. Thank you. I'm a resident
of District I, and I just wanted to
echo my kind of sadness to
hear that it sounds like support for programs
that the speaker really cared about. See, to succeed,
reentry my Brother's Keeper, things like that are
losing money. Can you share a little bit more
about the 1115 wafer and
then yeah. Is there anything that could be done
to help continue the support of these programs?
So the support of the programs not only come from, of course, the general
fund, but throughout the year, the directors do look to get
grant dollars that fund many of the programs that you were
speaking about. As council members, we also have council district service funds where
we work directly with the department to understand their
needs and identify ways in which we can support
specific programs that are unique to our community. So when it comes
to reentry or first responders, I know my office has allocated
dollars towards the My Brothers Keeper program, and so that's ways
in which we can assist and also supplement the department with
specific programming.
Next is okay, did you have
a thank you? Okay, you will? Yes.
I also just wanted to ask
about support for domestic violence
programs. Are there any initiatives
that would fall under Houston Health for that?
I believe there are, but let us make sure that we get you a specific
answer on that. I know that they work in collaboration with the Houston Police
Department, and many of us have an
interest in ensuring that we have dollars of programming towards domestic
violence. So please submit that answer directly to District
E at Houst Gov and we will respond
promptly.
Next is Saba Blanding.
Hi, I wanted to follow up on that about domestic violence.
Yesterday, Council Member Martin asked the chief of Police what
we should do about domestic violence. Then a speaker shared
that they were a survivor of domestic violence. I did not hear anyone take the
opportunity to ask them what would have helped them. Domestic violence
is a health issue, and my question is, what efforts is the city making
to engage survivors in organizations such
as Houston Area Women's Center to address interrupting
domestic violence, not just once it's happened? And then,
what is being done to specifically help support the health and
well being of Houstonians in possession of female reproductive organs?
According to the 2020 Report,
texas has 35 maternal deaths in 100,000.
To give some perspective, the national maternal mortality
rate for 2020 was 23.8 deaths per 100,000
live births, compared with a rate of 20.1 in 2019.
And of course, there are current and upcoming restrictions to accessing
abortion health care. Great questions as
it pertains to domestic violence, I know within the mayor's new One Safe
Houston plan, I believe he directed a million
dollars towards the Houston Area Women's Center, and those
are additional dollars that came through the Cares Act,
no matter of fact, ARPA dollars. And so that's
one way in which we as a council are trying to assist with
providing more resources on domestic violence.
But I believe council Member Cayman, did you want to chime in?
PABA, thank you for the question. And this is just a few examples, and we'd
be happy to follow up. I think the city is trying to leverage all
community partners, not just City of Houston, including the Harris
County Domestic Violence Coordinating Council going
back to COVID, and I can speak from COVID on right,
the no
COVID abuse program. So what we found is with domestic
abuse, a lot of survivors were trapped at
home with their families. Motion to extend. Sure.
So the city launched and brought together community partners
to launch that, working with Hawk to do online
reporting, texting services, anything to get the word out
and also educate and help. But in addition to that, the mayor added
in into the Office of Human Trafficking,
a specific charge now also to include domestic
violence in that. So that is now in the mayor's office as a permanent office.
In addition to that, throughout COVID, the additional housing
funding that we provided. Right. So you have the issues with
housing during the pandemic, you can't keep everyone in a shelter and
there was an increased need. So city funding,
council funding, hotels,
additional services, job training that was actually launched,
partnerships to actually train people. Because one of the things that happens with
domestic violence, you end up in a cycle because you are
dependent on that abuser financially. So the
city is actually starting to focus on job training programs. And we
can get you more information on that. There's a
whole list of things, but that's just a few examples,
not just the immediate response, immediate funding to Dart
HPD, but the holistic
approach that the city is trying to take in addressing the issue.
Are you also studying this within your Women's commission?
Is this one of the action items that
you all are looking at? I can't speak for the Women's
Commission because, again, that's an independent commission under the charge of the mayor.
But I do believe they are looking at that issue as well.
It's remaining at the forefront in a multitude
of ways. And then the city is supporting Houston Area Women's
Center in their expansion of their new campus. That's going to be
in District D, but there's
a lot of extraordinary work happening in that space.
Great, thank you. Thank you for your questions,
Mr. Broderick butler.
My name is Broderick Butler. I'm from northeast Houston. I respect the
health director's detailed responses to numerous members
of council. It would have been nice if he could have done the same for
the four public speakers. But if I were
here to ask him, I'd like to know from that list that he gave us
with all the red lettering, what his priorities would be.
So if you want to put yourself in his shoes and tell me what his
priorities would be for funding for the unfunded projects that he
has, I would love to hear that. Lastly, I'd like to make a statement.
I would like to acknowledge my council member, Tossa Jackson,
today. She stood 10ft tall for me because
she embodied the saying that the only thing necessary for
the triumph of evil is for good men and women
to do nothing. Thank you. Thank you.
No answer. I didn't hear a question
in any of that. I said to give me the priorities from the list of
the unfunded things the health director show. No,
you said to put ourselves in the shoes of the director.
You guys are answering the questions. If you would like
to ask us directly. We asked detailed questions of each of you,
gave detailed answers to each of you to the questions you gave.
We didn't have that opportunity. So since he is not here,
we can't talk over each other. So if you could give me these answers
for the list of the top priorities he would have
to choose from off that list of unfunded things,
I would appreciate it. If you can't, you can't. If you can, you can.
Directors report to the mayor. We as council members,
report to the public. So if you have a question for us,
then you can give that to us. Now. We can take your question and
submit that over to the director to provide an answer to you
from his standpoint, but we're not going to step in his shoes.
And the reason in which you all are speaking to us as a council is
because we report to you. The directors report to
the mayor in his administration, and so they were asked to
leave, and that's why their questions are being reported to us from the public.
Okay? So if you have a direct question to us, we can answer. If not,
if the question is for the director, we will submit for you,
and then we will provide their response. I'm not here to talk to you.
I'm here to talk to the director. So therefore, there's a flaw in
that logic of who I provide the question
to. He answered detailed questions from you,
and he couldn't do the same for us because he was dismissed.
So therefore, that is a flaw in this
whole process. And I didn't want to go here, but since
we are, that's a flaw in this process. Each of these individuals that
have stood before us are compensated very well. And the
question previously that I wanted to say that the airport
director said he gave a sterling list of people
that he lost. But you know what I would have said to him?
Competency gets compensation. And you're supposed
to build up people that leave you and
go to different departments in different countries and different sections and
exemplary and show that I was produced by
the Houston airport system. So that's what I would have said to
him. It's sad, but next
man up. Thank you, sir.
We have no more public speakers. And that concludes our health
department presentation.